[Music]
hey guys it's me jasmine and i forgot
hey everyone it's me jasmine and lunar
new year is right around the corner if
you know anything about lunar new year
the most important thing the food today
i'll be showing you three sweet treats
that i grew up eating while celebrating
lunar new year on my taiwanese family
side there's a whole list of different
foods both sweet and savory to be eaten
during lunar new year festivities and
these are just three out of many that i
loved from my childhood many different
cultures celebrate lunar new year in
their own way and they all have their
own special traditions though many also
overlap so lunar new year celebrates the
first year of the luna solar calendar
you might have heard lunar new year been
called chinese new year that really
encompasses chinese new year traditions
lunar new year encompasses all different
kinds of cultures that celebrate this
calendar date so you might see koreans
say happy korean new year vietnamese
people celebrate tet or say happy
vietnamese new year every culture has
their own special traditions the first
treat we're making are fried sesame
balls they're deliciously crispy yet
chewy and have a beautiful nuttiness
from both the sesame seeds and the red
beans they are super popular to eat
during lunar new year the round shape
and golden color stand for good luck and
they also increasingly grow in size
while cooking which stands for growing
prosperity so to begin we have some red
beans that have been soaking overnight
this is what they look like before
soaking we want to soak them to one
reduce the cooking time and to make them
more digestible we're going to start by
draining these we're going to add water
to a pot
and then add in our beans so once this
is boiling we're going to cover it up
and let it cook for an hour you'll see
that they are soft they're plump most of
the water has cooked down so we are now
going to add some sugar and we're just
going to mix this until it thickens into
a paste get your aggression out think of
every auntie that has asked you when are
you gonna get married
do you have a partner how much money do
you make i'm enough just kidding
everything's fine it's fine let's
transfer this to our bowl and as it
cools you'll notice that it starts to
slightly thicken our red bean paste is
ready let's get to making the dough
first i have some brown sugar here and
some hot water i'm gonna pour it over my
brown sugar and then we're just gonna
mix it all up until it fully dissolves
so i have some glutinous rice flour over
here the glutinous rice flour is so
important it gives it that mochi texture
so don't use all-purpose flour you're
going to be so sad okay so with the
flour i'm going to create a well in the
center and then we're going to pour in
our brown sugar syrup and now we're just
going to stir this for about five
minutes until everything's fully
combined and the dough is smooth i know
it looks a little wet right now but
we're going to start kneading it and
we'll firm up so let's transfer our
dough to my floured and clean counter so
i like to flour my hands first to keep
it from getting sticky start
incorporating everything together
and we're just gonna knead this for
about five minutes perfect so our dough
looks about ready you can see that it's
much firmer than before time to assemble
so first we're going to
cut our dough in half and we're going to
roll these out into logs until i have
eight pieces of dough so with each of
our divided pieces of dough we're going
to roll them into balls and every time
you have a finished ball go ahead and
place a damp paper towel over it to keep
it from drying i'm going to finish
rolling out these balls and then we'll
get to filling them
so it's time to assemble we're just
going to work with one at a time
remember to keep your damp towel over
the rest of your dough babies i saw a
comment the other day that was like why
do all tasty producers call their does
no babies why do we do that i know i
have no clue why flatten it so now i am
going to pinch the sides so that it's
slightly thinner than the rest of the
dough totally fine if you get some
cracks like this it'll still work we're
going to take one teaspoon of red bean
paste i usually just scoop it out with
my finger like this and we're just going
to seal it once it's sealed you can put
this face down on the counter and just
give it a slow swirl and it'll close up
on itself
and now we're going to coat it in our
sesame seeds make sure it's evenly
coated you can sprinkle them on like
this or you can just go ahead and
carefully push it around until it's
fully covered in the sesame seeds i'm
going to make seven more of these finish
off the dough and then we will get to
cooking them i have some vegetable oil
in a pot and i've brought it to 350 and
i'm just gonna fry about four of them at
once for 15 minutes once it puffs up it
kind of lives on one side so you're
going to want to kind of flip it so it's
evenly cooked and golden brown typically
we eat these on lunar new year because
the round shape and the golden color
symbolizes good luck also you'll see as
we fry these they'll puff up and they
increasingly swell
while we're frying it which stands for
growing prosperity when they start to
float to the top i know it's almost done
and the magic is about to happen oh my
gosh look at that it is so pretty
beautifully round golden brown
and look how big it got this is the
original size now that these guys are
done we're going to transfer them to a
wire rack these are done frying we're
going to fry up the rest of them and
then do a little taste test yay all of
our fried sesame balls are done they are
so pretty look at that golden brown
sheen the sesame seeds are nice and
toasty i can't wait to dig in let's give
it a try cheers
oh my gosh
look at that nicely sweet red bean
filling
the mochi in between the outside
so so chewy and the outside has that
fried flavor but not too oily so good
let's move on to the next one my mom's
favorite the second treat we'll be
baking up are these fortune cakes also
referred to as prosperity cakes or lucky
cakes and are extremely popular during
lunar new year the name fargo sounds
like wealth thus symbolizing good
fortune for the new year so to our small
saucepan we're gonna add our brown sugar
butter and water so we're just gonna
stir this until the sugar dissolves
about five minutes now that everything
is dissolved and has come together we
are going to remove this from heat and
let it cool to room temperature let's
make the batter first we're going to add
our self-rising flour sift that in there
also our rice flour
not glutinous regular rice flour and
then our baking powder now we're going
to quickly whisk this together so that
it's combined bring back our syrup here
then we're going to fold it in you
really just want to mix this until you
don't have any flour clumps because that
is not fun to eat so the molds we're
using today are egg tart molds if you
don't have them at home don't worry you
can totally use cupcake liners we're
going to take some batter and fill it in
there all the way to the top these cakes
they're deceiving it's got flavor but
it's light it's so delicious and you
can't really eat one it's super
addicting and the texture of it is very
different than a muffin these are
usually on the table once you
show up to a lunar new year festivity
some people eat it as they get in for
like a little snack before the meal some
people eat it for dessert my personal
favorite is to save it for the next
morning and have it for breakfast so i
was a little generous with my previous
molds and i've run out of batter for the
last one so i'm just gonna
top this one off with the remaining
and let's get steaming okay our steamer
basket is rapidly boiling so we're gonna
steam these in batches my steamer basket
will allow for about three at one time
and they do expand a little bit so try
to space them out if you can we're gonna
cover this up and steam for about 20
minutes do not do not open the lid bad
fortune for the year if you open it
i made that up our fortune cakes are
done
and they've cracked on top which is
exactly what we want a little background
behind this
growing up people would say it's good
luck because it's a smile and that
brings happiness to your new year but i
remember seeing this as a kid and
thinking that is a scary smile
and then i was told another story which
is that this is like a flower and each
time it cracks it makes a new petal the
more petals you get the more luck you
have in the new year so these ones this
is probably the one i would go for as a
kid cheers
[Music]
oh my gosh the texture is light yet
chewy and dense it's sweet it's savory i
love that this is perfect for any time
of the day breakfast lunch dinner snack
dessert all right this was really good
but let's move on to the next one which
is my favorite these last ones probably
my favorites for the day glutinous rice
balls or tang yuen they symbolize
reunion and togetherness and are
considered a good luck food to bring in
a peaceful and happy new year they sit
in a light yet flavorful brown sugar
ginger syrup that is so scrumptious and
so refreshing we'll start by making the
filling so this one is my favorite this
is the black sesame for the black sesame
filling we are going to start by
toasting this it's a little hard to see
once they're nicely toasted because the
color doesn't really change you'll know
when it's done when you get that nutty
aroma now that it's beautifully toasted
we are going to transfer this to our
food processor toss in our sugar
and we're going to process
so now we're going to process this until
it becomes a paste
perfect now we're going to add in some
butter and then we're going to process
it again until it becomes the
consistency of like a nut butter
all my black sesame desserts
i love this in a bun this in a milk tea
oh my god all right let's transfer this
to a bowl and then we're going to repeat
the same with our peanut filling so same
steps as last time except with peanuts
great these peanuts look like they are
beautifully toasted let's process this
in the food processor
our sugar
and we're going to process this
perfect we're going to toss in our
butter
look at this look at the consistency of
this this looks great we're going to put
both the peanut and black sesame
fillings in the fridge to chill for an
hour i'll be right back our fillings are
now out of the fridge look how firm they
are so this will make ten fillings i'm
gonna break it in half and
we're gonna do five from each of these
so we're just gonna roll it into balls
there's always a debate do you like your
glutinous rice balls in a hot broth or a
cold broth and my answer is always cold
i feel like it's so refreshing we're
gonna repeat this with our peanut
filling pre-portioning them out again
okay wonderful anything
that is food in ball form is so cute
okay let's make the brown sugar ginger
syrup so in a pot over medium heat i'm
going to add some hot water
brown sugar if you like it sweeter feel
free to add more brown sugar i'm just
thinking about my mom watching this
video being like why'd you add so much
sugar and of course some ginger now
we're gonna stir it until the sugar is
dissolved and let that cook
for about three to five minutes the
sugar is fully dissolved i am going to
let this cool to room temperature and
i'm going to throw it in the fridge to
cool let's make the dough so we are
starting with some glutinous rice flour
quarter cup of boiling water all right
just going to give this a quick whisk
now i'm going to add in a quarter cup of
room temperature water
i'm gonna switch over to my spatula here
okay this looks roughly combined let's
transfer this to our counter
and we're just gonna continue to knead
this for about two to three minutes just
until the dough is
nice and smooth i didn't make glutinous
rice balls growing up my family would go
out and get it as sort of a special
occasion but i think that made it a
little more special
like it was like a little treat once in
a while i like to roll it into a little
log divide it into two this one will
stay here and it's gonna remain white
i'm gonna put this one in my bowl from
earlier and i'm gonna add a couple drops
of pink food coloring while you're not
working on the white dough here make
sure to cover it with a damp paper towel
so it doesn't dry out so to mix this if
you like to get your hands dirty by all
means but i'm gonna put on a glove so it
doesn't look so gruesome these are nice
gloves so i actually like to coat it
like this like a dumpling so it stays
inside
and then i'll just continue
folding it over and over once it's
pretty generally dispersed then you can
knead it on the counter if you don't
want to use food coloring you can use
beet juice it looks so good
i feel like playing super smash now
so now we have both our doughs here so
with each piece of dough i am going to
divide it into 10 pieces about a
tablespoon per piece
so now we're going to roll these into
balls and when you're done just place
them on a tray next to you and then i'm
going to continue doing this until i
have all my dough rolled out and then
we'll get to filling them look at all
these beautiful balls
katie sorry
this is a family holiday
so what you're gonna do i like to just
press it down in the center
so we're going to put this on top of
your hand press it down to the center
and place a filling inside and then i
start to
loosen up on the bottom and start
working my fingers upwards
press it down
until you can get it fully enclosed
once it's sealed you can roll it again
on the counter
or on your palms you can see it's
cracking on the outside that's fine so
let's place this back here same thing
with the peanut with our white dough
we're going to press flat
make sure to not make the dough too thin
or else it could crack and all the
filling would
burst and be released into your
boiling water
so i put the peanut filling inside same
thing we're just gonna wrap it and seal
it close
all right i am gonna finish assembling
the rest of these usually the whole
family is helping but i'm on my own
today i have some water in a pot here
and we are going to boil six at a time
and totally okay to combine both of them
so drop it in gently
it'll stick to the bottom of your pan so
you just wanna carefully stir it they're
finally floating and we've cooked them
for another minute they are looking
absolutely good and we are going to put
them in the ice bath but before we do
that we have to check them to see if any
of them burst because if they do they do
not go in the ice bath because that ice
bath will just go directly inside the
rice ball luckily they all look great
just a quick ice bath place them in your
bowl now i'm going to pour the syrup
over my slotted spoon so none of that
ginger goes into my dessert
so here we have it the glutinous rice
balls otherwise known as tang yuan my
favorite i'm super excited to dig in
let's give it a try make sure you get
some broth cheers
mmm
black sesame the flavor is just this
rich nuttiness that doesn't compare to
other nuts and seeds it's so special all
right y'all that was so good i hope you
had a good time making these lunar new
year treats with me if you make any of
these recipes or celebrate lunar new
year in your own special way make sure
to snap a picture and tag me on
instagram happy new year
or as we say at home shiny and kaila bye
[Music]
[Music]
you